talking to this girl that assaulted this
dude about his loss because he was white
yeah uh first and foremost from the
bottom of my my heart I would like to
say I want to just kind of like oh [ __ ]
you God that maybe touched my nipple I
know
point number two if you're gonna play
the role of culture police if you're
gonna go to white people and say you're
not part of african-american culture I
don't want you to have anything black
you know what
cool fine there's no problem with that
from now on though your black ass better
never straighten your hair don't perm
that [ __ ] don't get it bleached and you
know why we perm that hair strictly
speaking if the fit in with white people
right we have a billion-dollar industry
that is based on white appropriation I
can't wait I see a black person wearing
blue contacts I'm like I'll spot them
contact straight out your eyes your
beautiful blue eyes point number three
the girl tried to say oh well dreadlocks
are part of my culture so I don't want
you wearing them no [ __ ]
open up a history books the oldest
evidence of dreadlocks comes from
ancient Egypt as well as ancient Greece
so your point is invalid mmm
even if you did have things well before
everyone else that's not doesn't give
you the right to tell people what they
can and can't do number four forget the
whole dreadlock historical aspect and
this on that because another aspect of
you that really bugged me a lot is she
assaulted him right she grabbed him she
was the aggressor you know any
really [ __ ] younger stop engine
pretended like she was the one being
assaulted in case anyone was watching
and then when she found out she was
being filmed she as a black woman
freaked out at the thought of people
recording her behavior ironic isn't it
because black people we pride ourselves
on keeping the police in check by
filming them so they don't abuse her
power and sudha thing God didn't she try
to use culture and its powers to abuse
his white dude and when she found out
that she was being caught in her abuse
isn't that mind-blowing that you became
the very thing that black people tend to
dislike the most the abuse of power here
don't understand the beautiful thing
about living in the Western world is
that we're a melting pot meaning someone
from Ethiopia can meet someone from
Jamaica can meet someone from Greece can
meet someone from India I get to eat
some curry some Kazuki whatever the [ __ ]
they make in Jamaica and I have a good
time we share a culture we bring people
in we invite them over we give them our
recipes we're talking [ __ ] Haitian
same [ __ ]
Haitians everywhere like no [ __ ] I'm a
psych Posse but what I'm trying to get
at is the beauty of being in the West is
that we're all sharing and you play
culture police you can't have this or
you can't have that you are destroying
the beauty of just honest integration so
I'm happy that the response has been so
against what she did and I hope going
forward instead of trying to condemn
people who want to take a piece of our
culture we can be understanding we can
show them the proper way to do things we
can try to just push that into it
because I think we could all use a
little more understanding in love with
one another from your unfolding and
conclusion [ __ ] that [ __ ]
vogue that beer